ça c'est bon tu sortes ta là et nous
attendait pas seulement que non
s'étaient bien préparés et appela jordan
je me coiffe est offert aux disparus bon
jordan joker ne présente plus la
dernière fois je t'avais appelé sur
cette chaîne youtube pour faire un gros
projet c'était si fort ce que tu avais
proposé c'était fou s'est découvert un
soir un soir un appel ça donnait toute
cette folie on a déjà des prix fait on
va pas là au débriefing aujourd'hui
jordan je t'appelle pour tout l'inversé
peu de préparation le concept est pas au
fond qu'on s'était pas ouf le concept
est incroyable tu mais attendez vous
êtes animateur ou quoi on avait lancé
pour nous faire regarder ce que vous
avez devant vos yeux
fantastique jean évident gymnase dommage
fantastique gymnastique qui se souvient
de cette vidéo qu'on avait fait à
l'époque il ya deux ans avec un mix mxc
gens doivent faire des petits à coup et
quand il va vers vie tout va falloir le
lâcher ils atterrissent directement là
bas
moi je m'en souviens à lui qu'à
enchanter jordan je le referai pas une
fois de plus bien joué à l'époque avait
un concept lecture réussite a droit de
faire un tweet avec mon compte twitter
honte et que j'ai réussi j'ai le droit
de partout tech bon tranquille c'était
juste un gage et autour des tweets et
tooway voilà le prix j'ai du mépris g et
tu as raison d'avoir direct du mépris
c'est marrant tu perds il se passe un
truc aujourd'hui mec c'est super non non
en fait je traînais sur tik tok je tombe
sur une vidéo où il ya un truc avec un
gymnase et ce n'est pas le jeu que j'ai
fait avec un mix m accroche-toi
assieds-toi assis toi c'est toi parce
que là c'est un truc de donc en fait ce
n'est pas le jeu moi je me dis
[Musique]
je vais sur internet je tape gymnase
jouer et je vois qu'il ya eu 2e jouer et
que personne malade et on va le faire
aujourd'hui oui sans aucun concept fois
stylé mais au moins c'est clair quoi
c'est parti
au cerveau chine basse c'est une jeune
ces jeunes gymnastes troisième fois non
mais là je peux toucher demain
oui c'est bafé tu rimac cette blague
mais j'ai envie qu'ils redeviennent à la
mode trop content d'atlanta il est
européen fort et qui est un mec là et ce
serait incroyable c'est parti sur
twitter qu'on lance le challenge
attends je vais quand même la sortir son
passing de suffoquer c'est vrai très
certainement demain du coup elle a été
absent mais après tout ce qu'on fait
c'est tout
tac étape 2 tac
étape 3 il manque un élément c'est ça le
point il faut toujours ajouter des
points dans les jours
il pense à un truc drôle ils disent mais
c'est pas un jeu juste et du coup ils
font des points donc quand tu appuies la
whey gymnastes pas vers l'avant cette
direction il bute et du coup ces mamans
partir là dessus une fois que ses mains
sont là dessus tu appuies pour que ça
rentre
le gymnaste en l'air et le but c'est
qu'ils atterrissent droit ici c'est un
jeu indé le but aujourd'hui d'avancer qu
au moins demain nous réussissent une
fois parce que c'est hyper dur en vrai
et ensuite une fois que noir chacun
réussi c'est que l'un de nous face la
plus belle figure ever c'est toi qui
commence joue la compétition j'aimerais
juste que tu fois parce que sinon la
vidéo serait déjà fini ses règlements
c'est incroyable le gars première et
c'est fort travail ok rien faire ce que
je fais c'était pas si maman s'en est
pas si mal on peut changer la dynamique
aérodynamique des bras non non je ne dis
pas c'est qu'il a vraiment mal et est
donc elle parce que choisir c'est en
superman un peu près des rails dans les
bras une utilité vous vraiment que tout
le monde se regarde mais c'est
incroyable je te laisserais que les
langues des bras et bazire j'ai vu que
le faire bien plus perso un beau à temps
at home and we emballages des produits
est face au public le public et la casa
ou wazi qui fait la meilleure figure ses
filles c'est un bel effort dont va
verser à tous bords et plus douce a
triplé
ben moi je te l'avais dit celle-là qui
alors aux gants ce web mais je suis
abasourdi sur le 100 points en plus
oui c'est ça que j'ai cessé en faisait
là ça commence bien moi je pense si je
peux donner un conseil ta manière de
jouer correspond plus à un angle vous
pouvez tout oui j'écoute pas un angle
d'environ 50 de baisse ok tu est éclatée
en fait je me sens que tu es sûreté
réserve là à temps de montrer réellement
solide
toi aussi tu de ce côté là donc du coup
tu peux mieux en inverse
je me sens vachement il faut vraiment
faire quand son corps a basculé sylvie
bermann un journal
je pense juste un petit peu
l'entraînement c'est normal placée juste
en j'appuie juste pour voir comment le
film dis-moi pas qu'elle marche à chaque
fois j'étais content des données de ouf
tu t'attendais à faire des musiques non
je m'attendais il était battu rennes
gildas 13 250 non pas comme ça tu l'as
fait trop tôt c'est bon j'ai eu en fait
c'est quoi ton jeu devrait filmer je
sais tu là
ok nouvelles infos seront matures on
prend les gens un peu des infos on va
filmer ans l'homo pour voir ce qui va
pas en fait le gars je prends un angle
de 45
non mais prend un truc fixe un peu plus
large prend truffé simple pleure un peu
plus de profils peut-être pour qu'on
voit bien vissé mes plans sont jointes à
kate et jamie ça passe ici qu'est-ce qui
va pas mais je veux voir les images trop
tôt trop tôt du coup en fait plus tu vas
le faire tu as plus il va aller vers la
bas que tu vas faire tôt puis va rester
comme ça vas-y tartas oublie pas tarder
[Musique]
tard
ça c'était bien c'était ça bien oui dans
une bonne série allez allez allez allez
allez très passante on a fait une belle
galerie nommé gaverie un truc de fou on
se rapproche à un macaron sur la roche
de la facture sera pas dans l'équipe
oui mais voilà devient un problème
jardin ouais on a une équipe depuis le
début il faut pas voir ça comme une
compétition je pensais que c'était un
peu sa voix n'ont rien jordan tu nous
sommes une équipe maintenant oui il a
beaucoup plus rien journal aurait
peut-être trouvé une équipe pour deux
rôles à l'esprit toujours plus le temps
passe plus ça fait non je te jure mec je
comprends pas qu'on en ait pas qu'elle
est en fait tu as la vidéo du gars qui
fait les triple vie qu'on voit comment
il faut que tu vas être abasourdis ton
ego va être du score mais là tu es prêt
[Musique]
attends que oui nos fils et un bras
droit et un bras en l'air parfaite son
bras y fait tac et ensuite à fort rapp
filles et oisy stock c'est ça ok c'est
ça excuse moi je te jure malades
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dr face à paul tapas avec l'asie tu vas
y arriver tu étais à sa jambe et je suis
à sa grâce à ce gain permet tout on est
juste debout comme un seul font tous les
tubes en bout tu vas y arriver mais
c'est ton destin qui joue sur cette
table qui est en fait un meuble de
rangement en métal jordan abandonne va
je sais que c'est dur surtout qu'il y
aura tout fait de travers je dois
d'abord je sais que c'est dur crois en
toi et confiance analyse c'est pas ta
faute
c'est un faux jordan nord n'ont pu
tester à vif ok je me suis mis en
gymnase je vais tenter de figure moi
j'en ai marre de faire comme des tic toc
coeur qui bat samantha ça commence à
devenir parties rapides
[Musique]
elle fait face à théo plus à la commune
la mer noire plus guère bravo isabelle
tu as enfin atteint le niveau de
gymnastique suffisant pour pouvoir
éliminer les trois personnes qui ont
enfermé nous sommes dans ces jouets de
type fokker après cela nous serons
libérés de ce maléfice
ok maman je suis prête tiens prends se
lancent les chaînes à reconnaissance de
mouvements il pourra être utile vas-y ma
fille
la première cible sera madame muller la
prof de sport du lycée
sekkaki a voulu nous faire disparaître
parce que tu vas tu es toujours sa fille
au complète de gym régional ce pas avant
ce que je voulais faire ce très long
c'est bon je la vois
maintenant au tour de son frère et se
marrer c'est le qui ont transvaser nos
âmes dans ces figurines
attention ils sont plus dangereux ça
vole bas de page arrivant je vais en
tuer ni qu'est ce qu'il veut lui
ok j'ai le frère en vision ils n'ont
plus que le mari je suis dessus
le broker c'est parti mais y va où
mange vient d'arriver sur place le beau
temps
[Musique]
ça marche ou pas avec là ça ne marche
jamais mais pas mieux à isabelle mec m
en tape isabelle tu veux ton teint on va
finir avec le meilleur saut éleveurs bon
allez je leur fais un père fait comme ça
il me remettre dans ma boîte et ils
rentrent leur mère
le meilleur saut ever ça nous regarde
nous a été gâché ma vie bon c'est la fin
de cette deuxième vidéo
non non il ya un dernier petit nom c'est
que tous lancés soit bien ou pas il
marque la fin de la vidéo alors prépare
toi bien des pertes hier j'ai adoré
désolé il n'y avait peut-être pas
forcément beaucoup de concept mais juste
j'avais envie de jouer à jordan alors on
bouge très heureux qu'elle ait pas comme
ça c'est immonde
je vais faire rentrer dedans tu as dit
quoi je dis ça ce que tu as fait en
poterie je vais la faire entrer dedans
pardon peut-être 18 ans voir aujourd'hui
c'est normal tout dernier merci à tous
pour ce qu'on me suis régalé et like et
pour un des pilotes 2 je suis pas sur
l'oust voir d'autres épisodes sur sa non
moi j'ai kiffé merci à tous le fasse
j'ai fait une heure et demie train je
vais refaire la même chose dans l'autre
sens
[Musique]
tu es fier de toi t'es fier de toi c'est
parce que je voulais tu as vu la poêle
d'isabelle qu'il ait visé je voulais
juste qu'on s'amuse c'est tout je
pensais pas que c'était réel tout ça dgo
je n'ai pas vraiment eu et lucas au
[Musique]
maire